Let me go next to our caller from the seven
zero one area code.
Who's calling today from seven Oh one.
Hi David.
Hey, who's this?
Uh, I'm uh, this is Chris.
Uh, my question is, uh, do you think Joe Biden
is betting everything on South Carolina and
how much will that actually matter to him
in the race?
Well, incredibly.
There's a recent poll out of South Carolina
where Biden is only up five.
I mean, Biden early was expected to crush
it's South Carolina wind by 20 or 25 points.
One poll recently says he's only up five.
So his advisors did say he doesn't need to
win Iowa or New Hampshire because he's going
to do well in Nevada and South Carolina and
there's more delegates there.
That may be true except in Nevada now he is
almost in a virtual statistical tie and in
South Carolina he's not doing really as well
as he was.
Here's the problem for Joe Biden.
How does he justify continuing to raise money,
right?
If you are a centrist Democrat, you want to
see someone like Biden boot edge, edge Klobuchar
or Bloomberg win.
How do you justify donating to Biden when
he did so poorly in Iowa, you might say, I'm
going to donate to Pete, or you might say,
I'm just going to stop donating and hope Bloomberg
takes over because he doesn't even need my
money.
He's got hundreds of millions that he's already
spent.
So for me, the problem with Biden is less
about the results in these first few elections.
It's more about how does he keep raising money?
How does he justify saying, Hey, give me your
money because he is not the exciting candidate.
It's basically saying, Hey, I'm a known entity
and I'm the statesman and I have experienced
any lost in Iowa.
So that's the real concern for Biden.
I think
that makes perfect sense.
Can I just add, uh, the last color, the reason
that there are, there is no established from
Democrats in Wyoming is because they're all
Republicans and they want to be elected.
That's a, that's an interesting point.
Yeah.
If you're a progressive, then you're a Democrat.
But if you're even remotely centrist, you
realize that the way to win is to be a Republican
in that state.
Love the show.
Thanks David.
All right.
Thank you for the call.
Appreciate it.
Chris